it's a job made in heaven you flying
it's almost as if you're a bird looking
down and everything so you seeing things
here that people just don't see every
day drones are the unmanned miniaturized
aircraft of the future once the preserve
of the military today these planes and
helicopters are on the verge of
revolutionizing the civilian workplace
from agriculture to industry the
specialized skills of the people who fly
them are in ever higher demand they look
like miniature cross but they not they
not model aircraft they they far from it
they full of technology in South Africa
the government's turned to a drone
company at the cutting edge of this
technology to help tackle an age-old
problem poaching
is no other commercial drone operation
of this magnitude being flown at the
moment and the whole project is really
to detect poachers on the ground to
detect illegal activity in national
parks where endangered species are being
poached at an alarming rate
they'll infiltrate the park they'll come
in shooter Rhino they'll literally HEK
the face of the Rhino off to remove the
horn it's the most horrific crime scene
that you could ever imagine
you'll see the COFF wandering around
aimlessly all the mothers lying bleeding
to death it's it's it's a murder scene
barn and that's what has to be prevented
at all costs in 2014
poachers killed over 1,200 Rhino in
South Africa more than 2/3 of them in
Kruger National Park robbed Hannaford's
team began operations there toward the
end of that year we've had some
intelligence from the Ranger he believes
that there going to be some incursions
it looks like the karna missions that
we're gonna have to fly this evening are
gonna have to be stealthy missions so
it's going to be lights off from their
mobile launch unit the team and their
drones can see far into this enormous
site a park that's virtually the size of
Wales Rangers on the ground alone
couldn't hope to police it especially as
darkness falls
most poaching does take place at night
that's when the incursions happen it's
dark the poachers obviously feel
incredibly safe so lifetime is the
obvious time for anybody to be fiddling
around in the bush Rob's drone
Michener's anticipate new ways to
prevent needless animal deaths
but the same technology is framing the
future for many humanitarian assignments
- in Texas the mission is disaster
rescue you stand out in the cold in the
rain and then as soon as the weather
clears up with enough visibility you
launch dr. Robin Murphy has been flying
drones at the sites of major incidents
since 2005 when the United States faced
one of the worst natural disasters in
his history Hurricane Katrina miles and
miles of devastation and the responders
called us out from Louisiana to help
them in New Orleans with large areas
inaccessible emergency responders even
in boats struggled to spot people in
need of rescue Robins drones could
reveal them and in virtually real-time
in less than eight minutes you could get
data back surveys videotape then things
that would normally take two to three
days to get the information any other
way
Robin's experience in the aftermath of
Katrina and 17 other disasters convinced
her that drones will become essential
tools for every emergency rescue team
they're not replacing people they're
doing things they can't do they fly
lower and go at different angles that
would be horribly unsafe
from the men helicopters so it's
complimentary it's freeing them up to do
their the jobs that they do well and
using these smaller vehicles to get in
and see data that you can't get from a
satellite or you can't get from the
Mantella copter but drones aren't
restricted to major disasters they're
already being flown in local search and
rescue operations across the world
responders gain a vital new perspective
from the skills that Robin and her
fellow pilots have honed you are
basically doing a Vulcan mind-meld with
the robot it's doing the flying you're
doing the looking and directing I think
of it it's kind of similar to riding a
horse or training a dragon but from
miles away so even if it seems like it's
a video game there's Steve the deep need
to try to get the right data as fast as
humanly possible so to actually help and
make a difference
at Kruger National Park in South Africa
Rob Hannaford has plotted a nighttime
mission for his anti poaching drone with
the planes flight on automatic Rob and
his colleague monitor its live video
feed for any sign of suspicious activity
in the darkness I suspect it's in that
area that we need to have a good look
through through that riverbed the
aircraft is equipped with a with a
thermal imaging camera and a thermal
imaging camera we'll look at anything
that potentially gives off heat so body
heat from a human being and body heat
from an animal it's all a heat signature
human beings appear very different on
the displays the other thing that we
look for is vehicles on on on roads
because we off to six o'clock in the
evening here it shut down so that's a
big alarm bell as well the car driving
along there Hey
cross the bridge
I knew he's gonna stop my sisters shake
you can see the passengers clearly
having a good look out of the window and
when it comes around it looked like the
the driver was also out of the window I
think we must get this checked out I
think we have to agreed when they spot
something out of the ordinary Rob and
his team passed the drones GPS
coordinates to Park Rangers on the
ground
it's technology that can give them the
jump on a group of would-be poachers it
also helps to rule out an innocent game
drive that has stopped to watch a pride
of lions on the prowl
operations like this are starting to
have a dramatic impact on poaching in
South Africa if this activity we have
one of these in the air we generally
find that poaching in that area slows
down in in some cases as ground to a
halt
the drone business is building
everywhere
in the construction industry in mining
and agriculture thousands of companies
globally are drawn to the drones
extraordinary eye for detail
what if flies over and takes the series
of hundreds or maybe a thousand
photographs that's its only job the
camera just clicks away as its flying in
captures every bit sophisticated
computer modeling from these images has
turned drones into powerful surveying
tools they spot the tiniest changes on
busy work sites some down to a couple of
centimeters doing the job for a third of
the price of a satellite and at up to 15
times the resolution like the technology
behind the drones Peter Blake's origins
were in the military I was a squadron
commander flying tactical jets in the
military Landing and aircraft carriers
deploying around the world so I've gone
from flying 30 million-dollar airplanes
to two small quad copters PETA's new
employer sky catch is one of a cluster
of new Silicon Valley drone startups
their rise is fueling an industry that
will soon be worth billions of dollars
to the US economy and that construction
site is small so maybe we can get these
guys to do all three of these projects
since they have the through the aircraft
and the cameras to support it yeah and
other people they can split up the work
now Peter is nurturing a new generation
of freelance drone pilots to help with
an expanding global workload we explain
that to people as being uber for drones
but we we pride ourselves in helping
train people that are really starting
from scratch
it's an early attempt to professionalize
the thousands of men and women who owned
their own drones from you know high
school kids who were fascinated with
with robotics to retired airline pilots
and everybody in between
we're helping give them an avenue to
turn this into a business and earn some
money from it I definitely see this as a
future and it gives a whole generation
of people access to this this sort of
technology
the drone industry as a whole will
launch over a hundred thousand new
careers over the next few years
many more of tomorrow's workers look set
to follow today's drone pilots the job
satisfaction they're coming out and
knowing at the same time that you out
there protecting something and helping
these animals stay alive enormous
satisfaction
you